many of the western sanctions imposed on
russia since the invasion of ukraine are
aimed at restricting russia's access to
hard international currency
but as the country is the world's
biggest exporter of oil and gas this
has proven to be a challenge now
russia's energy revenues are estimated
at about 700 million dollars per day for
crude oil and refined products
and at about 400 million dollars per day
for natural gas sent via pipelines to
the european union the proceeds of oil
and gas exports account for nearly half
of russia's federal budget the eu has
stopped short of a full oil and gas
embargo instead it plans to cut by
nearly two-thirds its gas imports from
russia by the end of this year and the
goal is to make europe independent from
all russian fossil fuels well before
2030. so far though germany and other eu
eu countries still depend heavily
on russian energy here's what that means
natural gas from russia ever since the
country started a war in ukraine a
crucial resource has become a highly
politicized issue amid germany's
dependence on russian gas the initial
order was clear use as little as
possible
we're in a situation where i have to
make very clear that every hour every
kilowatt hour of energy that we can save
helps
suggestions included no private sauna
use and turning down the heat
but domestic heating accounts for less
than a third of germany's natural gas
consumption while industry accounts for
just over a third the rest is used to
produce electricity or by trading
commerce and others
amongst the biggest users of gas is the
chemical industry in the southern german
town of ludwig's hoffen market leader
basf sprawls across an area of 10 square
kilometers
37 terawatt hours of natural gas are
used here annually a full 3 percent of
germany's overall consumption
almost half of that is used as a raw
material
to make ammonia for example used in
nitrogen fertilizers
germany's farmer's organization is
concerned that natural gas shortages now
could lead to supplies of wheat rapeseed
and important vegetables running low in
2023
experts say the current rise in food
prices could be followed by empty
shelves next year
another product based on natural gas
acetylene used in plastic wrappers and
glue in perfume and shampoo
basf says that it would be impossible to
quickly replace natural gas as a raw
material for these products
the chemical industry accounts for three
percent of germany's gdp
no wonder experts worry about the impact
of a gas shortage for the sector
all right let's get the view of gunther
wolff on this he is the president of the
brugel think tank welcome to dw now as
we've heard uh russian energy is very
important to the german economy and
german energy firm juniper says it is
ready to meet russia's demand and pay
for gas in rubles as seems to be the
case for italy's any what would that
mean
well i think it's very clear that russia
tries to
play around with european countries and
the ruble uh
invoicing trick is basically political
game to divide um and and rule europe so
i think it is very important in the
current situation that we do not accept
uh being held hostage and that europe
the european union has a unified
position vis-a-vis russia and actually
uh imposes
uh smart sanctions on russia so that
russia
cannot make quite as much profits as it
can currently
in the most extreme scenario we would
cut off um russian imports
completely however the resistance to
that is very big and we've seen some
sectors really being very vocal
i think
a better scenario and politically more
feasible scenario will be one where
we would actually tax so impose a tariff
on russian imports imports from russia
so as to reduce the extraordinarily high
profits that putin is currently making i
want to talk about that in a second but
when european companies are adhering to
the kremlin's demand of making payments
for gas deliveries in rubles doesn't
this united european front showing
cracks
yeah i mean i i think it is showing
cracks and it is totally inacceptable uh
if companies uh deviate from from what
governments and what the european union
as a whole has decided currently and so
there needs to be
a clear line from our political leaders
limiting
that kind of a behavior
because it is completely unacceptable in
a situation of war
no political system can accept that
that some companies played that played
the game of of the dictator on the other
side
now you propose uh
taxing um russian gas deliveries to
europe um what would the advantage be
there vis-a-vis the current way things
are going
well i mean the main problem currently
is that um we are talking about
embargoes we are gradually phasing out
and in the meantime the price has has
risen quite quite significantly and we
continue to import so the revenues that
that putin and russia are actually
making are very very high and so so
we need to really think about how we can
bring down those revenues because they
do fund 40 more than 40 percent
of the russian federal budget and
therefore fund the war so what we need
to do is uh i mean the the most extreme
scenario is a full embargo and there i
think politically it's more
controversial but i would also argue
that the chemical industry in germany is
really over charging its case um if even
in the case of a full embargo there
would still be gas for bsf
in in germany
it would come from from mobile terminals
lng terminals but i think the really
better solution that will be easier to
pass is a tariff so a tariff
a unified european tariff imposed on uh
all imports coming coming from russia
and that would basically tax away the
extraordinary profits that russia is
making gantrum wolf president of the
think tank brugel thank you for your
thoughts